okay this clip from my conversation with
richard dawkins does require a little
bit of a setup we just finished talking
about the genetic code the set of rules
that the ribosome uses when reading a
gene to build protein and we were
talking about that amazing similarities
between the genetic code and machine
language in computers so this very basic
digital language of zeros and ones that
computers use the genetic code uses
nucleotides instead of zeros and ones
for its digits early on in richard
dawkins career he spent a lot of time
working with computers and they inspired
a lot of his work in genetics later and
here he's going to talk about an analogy
between things that we find in genetics
and what we find in higher level coding
so beyond machine language the actual
higher level coding that programmers use
when designing software there are good
analogies which we can still use
when i first starting started
programming for
the
macintosh
um i was no longer using machine code i
used machine code on pdp-8s and
um yes mostly pdp-8 sorry and and apple
ii of course a lot with apple too um
when i switched to the mac i was no
longer using machine code i was using
high level
languages and there the analogy was
rather nice with other aspects of
genomics because
um
when you're programming for
the mac anyway when i was doing it you
have a thing called a toolbox
which is a set of pre-written
routines which do things like pull down
menus
shrinking windows
um
setting up um those little boxes where
you click and click the mouse in and it
changes to a
to a dot or an x
um so those were all toolbox routines
which which were built in
and that's a very good analogy for
what's going on in the genome people
were rather puzzled when they discovered
that the human genome
is no bigger than that of other mammals
like a mouse for example you sort of
think well human dignity should require
a lot more information
actually the genome is about the same
size and the reason is
that both
mice and people
in their embryology are calling
routines from the same toolbox of
routines it's just like on on a computer
microsoft word and excel and
all the other programs that we regularly
use
they're all calling upon the same
toolbox routines
that's why they look so alike that
that's why the
process of pulling down a menu
or shrinking a window expanding a window
etc it all looks the same whatever
program you're using and the reason is
that they're all using the same built-in
repertoire of toolbox routines and it's
just like that with the genome
so the mammalian genome has this set of
toolbox routines and the difference
between a person and a mouse is the
order in which those toolbox routines
are called
so there is a very nice analogy there
which is at a sort of higher level
than the punch the tape analogy we were
talking about earlier
so that was just a clip from my
conversation with richard dawkins you
can see the whole thing there's a link
to that down below subscribe to this
channel if you enjoyed it
i upload clips pretty regularly talks
and conversations and presentations that
i've done on genetics and evolution and
i am gearing up to start doing weekly
videos again here that are completely
new completely fresh